sich 2006 kann ich eine stufe und viele
am morgen nachmittag irgendwie ihr vater
ist die schweiz so die unterhaltung
schweizerdeutsch ich fange einfach mal
angefangen und dann ist förmlich
explodiert ich habe das wissen zu meiner
wohl nicht alle millionen follower fans
wissen im tv über 200.000 kann
ich habe sechs weltweit über 32 kann ich
eine youtube account wo ich jetzt knapp
90.000 kann also das summiert sich alles
und alle jetzt wenn man die zahlen
zusammen zählt auf 1,2 millionen
[Musik]
wir als content creators oder info in so
will man uns nennt wir machen hat das
ganze ein bisschen menschlicher wo ich
glaube das ist genau das was menschen
wollen morgen herr alle gesichter hinter
den kulissen
jetzt sind großmann ganzen land ist
eigentlich nur positiv besetzt empfunden
[Musik]
die welter influenza ist das internet
sie filmen und fotografieren sich selbst
posten die bilder auf den social media
plattformen und verdienen damit geld
viel geld
geschätzte fünf bis zehn milliarden
dollar werden influenza alleine in
diesem jahr umsetzen
die neuen stars sind nicht mehr
berühmtheiten aus musik und film sondern
ganz normale menschen
ihre fans sind follower je größer die
gefolgschaft umso wertvoller ein punkt
mein name ist julia graf ich bin youtube
ihren content social media
persönlichkeit man nennt uns auch in
freundlich 40 beruht postet ich versuche
es macht spaß macht in den usa verdienen
die erfolgreichsten stars im internet
seine einzige empfehlung einen einzigen
post bis zu mehreren hunderttausend
dollar
die junge kundschaft wird nicht mehr
über klassische werbung erreicht
stattdessen setzen die unternehmen auf
influenza die mit ihren empfehlungen das
kaufverhalten ihrer follower
beeinflussen
was also ist influenza marketing
schamlose schleichwerbung die neueste
effiziente strategie der welt musste
sind voll aber nichts anderes als
unkritische konsumenten lose empfänger
von werbebotschaften oder ist alles nur
ein hype ein phänomen unserer zeit alles
mit ford entstand aber sich nicht sehr
viel plane
oftmals muss ich vielleicht sachen mache
muss ich vielleicht wie ist es mit how
damit beruf ist das bild dann muss
trotzdem perfekt
der basler zirkusshow ist einer der
umtriebigsten instagram der
deutschschweiz
sie arbeitet als social media manager
bei einem schweizer privatsender auf
seinen eigenen accounts folgen ihm über
1,2 millionen junge menschen
das sind mehr als die täglich verteilten
exemplare der grössten schweizer
gratiszeitung ursprünglich okay bei der
metro um die jetzt mittlerweile seit
über 25 jahren in der schweiz mit vater
des fitz und mittlerweile beherrscht
kann ich meine eigenen spruch weniger
gut als schützen
so brauchte heute zum suchen sie das
alte haus zugestimmt haben viel
schlanker vorstellen aber die nutzer
gültig
wir haben die lage macht im detailhandel
und ich bin ziemlich uns fliegt sie mit
dem erscheinen so ziemlich hamsterrad
mäßig sie unterhalt privat hobbymäßig
kann ich halt gerne weiter unterhalten
und zum lachen braucht und ich habe mich
halt wie kann ich das mache
und so bin ich halt swissmint haben wir
erkannt gestartet ich angefangen bilder
poster videos posten und es sind halt
immer mehr und mehr wurde david mit
liebe nicht im spiegel besucht dann
steht da war schrieb marc h in die
hässliche gesicht wissen wahrscheinlich
so entstanden bevor das ganze überhaupt
losging ist nicht immer sachlich sucht
kann so viel wie zwei jugendliche
ansprechen
ich mach das jetzt einfach mal und das
ist wirklich ein bisschen stücke wird
spontan entstanden viele morgen können
schlafen einfach mal das bild porsche
durch schweizerdeutsch und dann hat sich
das halt so oft schaut aufmerksam
geworden so der städtische über das tor
gemacht hat und jetzt nach fünf jahren
zeitlich mit dem 1,2 millionen verlobt
gezählt hat keine sandwich essen kann
war ganz wenig
da spritzt franken
videos
alles klar also twitter facebook social
media geschenk das ihr denn wir direkt
auf der karte für selb ist für small
talks und ich mache das gern also für
mich schluss absolut kein problem
problematisch wird es halt einfach wenn
ich zum beispiel der strand gang und ich
habe mir den irgendwie 50 jugendliche
mit dem handy sunnitisch und waren das
wort jahr von mir jetzt den schon zuvor
um genau genommen
[Musik]
toll
eine ganz andere zielgruppe hat julia
graf im visier
die studierte politikwissenschaftlerin
hat ihr hobby zum beruf gemacht
ich mache seit 2008 videos auf youtube
über das thema beauty lifestyle
gesundheit habe und zur koch videos
einfach so ein bisschen verschiedenen
themen
und ja ich hab das in 2008 angefangen
als hobby hat natürlich nie gedacht dass
da wirklich ein ganzes business oder ein
ganzes geschäft daraus entsteht und hab
das dann zu meinem beruf machen kann was
natürlich super tolle ist julia graf hat
inzwischen 800 tausend abonnenten und
abonnenten und gehört damit zu den
erfolgreichsten youtube in der schweiz
diese videos für mich in meinem eigenen
heim studio wo ich mir selber aufgebaut
habe ich mache auch wirklich alles
selber also filme und mache die bilder
und schnittprogramm alles das habe ich
mir selbst beigebracht und hab das dann
wirklich am abend und am wochenende
gemacht und habe dann überlegt ja ich
könnte das ja mal online stellen und
schauen was passiert auf youtube und das
ist eigentlich von anfang an relativ gut
gelaufen und ja aber die zuschauer haben
gleich immer feedbacks gegeben
kommentare und es hat mich natürlich
dann immer angespannt weiterzumachen wo
dann der kanal größer geworden ist und
wo dann auch die firmen darauf
aufmerksam geworden sind haben die
pepsico nackte h das sind ja leute auf
youtube die so einfach produkte zeigen
oder die halt einfach videos von sich
selbst machen und dann hat das
angefangen dass man halt erstmal von
eher kleineren firmen angeschrieben
worden sind das sind meist so die in die
brenz gewesen bei die überhaupt kein
budget hatten für traditionelle werbung
zu machen und da hat man dann vielleicht
ein paar lidschatten oder so gratis zu
bekommen
und erst in den letzten paar jahren ist
das wirklich ein wirklich großes
geschäft geworden weil dann die großen
firmen also wirklich die bekannten
marken dass auch darauf aufmerksam
geworden sind jetzt knapp unter 800
tausend follower auf youtube dann habe
ich noch einen zweiten kanal dort habe
ich jetzt knapp 100000 fast 97.000 oder
so auf meinem zweiten lok intern also da
habe ich dann videos wo nicht nur
beautycenter sein könnte auch ganz
andere themen
dann habe ich eben facebook
das sind 250.000 mittel sind 57.000 und
dann instagram noch mal so für 50.000
euro
mein name ist martin ich bin psychologe
und arbeitet am institut für customer
insight an der universität st gallen in
der forschung
wer heutzutage mediale reichweite
aufbauen kann das hat sich fundamental
verändert früher war das so dass einfach
letztendlich beispielsweise im fall von
der band hat man hobbymäßig musik
gemacht bis ein plattenlabel groß
promotet hat und das plattenlabel hat
letztendlich entschieden wer würdig ist
zuschauer zu haben heute kann jeder
versuchen reichweite aufzubauen und
seine inhalte zu vertreiben
und das hat sich radikal geändert
dadurch gibt es viel mehr kleinere
sender sozusagen in den sozialen
netzwerken und natürlich auch
unglaublich viele empfänger aber es gibt
viel mehr sender mittlerer größe was es
früher nicht gab
in seiner forschungsarbeit untersuchte
martin falten die zwischenmenschlichen
beziehungen in sozialen
und deren auswirkungen auf das
konsumverhalten was eine
kaufentscheidung letztendlich
beeinflusst ist ein sehr komplexes
psychologisches phänomen ich glaube dass
keine antwort die man in einem satz
geben kann was aber schon wichtig ist
ist letztendlich dass wir denjenigen
jahren empfehlung gibt und darum geht
selber influenza marketing dass wir
denjenigen vertrauen das ist ein ganz
großer faktor für sex video für meine
fans dass kam mit denen europa park es
wird einfach ins klo sexvideos sie und
das konzept am 12.4 online dienst zu tun
[Applaus]
also ist die ganz große party in europa
der skoda roomster update das heißt
alles gratis und der durchaus mitmachen
dann tut ihnen begleitet markiert die
schlachten mit 100 musikern used to zero
kommentar
da wurde nicht jeder wie sie so meine
erlaubnis am namen ist manuela und ich
bin leiter vom center für die geologie
neuester der hwz hochschule für
wirtschaft in zürich ich glaube soziale
medien sind deshalb so erfolgreich weil
sie halt dass menschliches bedürfnis
befriedigen
der mensch möchte gern verbunden sich
mit anderen menschen möchte ich ein füße
etwas andere menschen so machen was sie
nicht
netzwerker sind die gründe so macht und
social media hat mit anna so ist das zur
verfügung stelle einfach in digitaler
form und das ist natürlich einfach zum
konsumieren aus live-version influences
im marketing das schon immer gehen sie
einfach ein anderer name kam ein roger
federer und george clooney wo werbung
machen für irgendeine form von
influences sie weiterentwickeln wie sie
fachlich truestuff maschine sondern sie
weiter genau wie sie bis repräsentieren
im renault glaubt und qualität anspruch
das kann man jetzt natürlich von oben
aber deklinieren zum vom testimonial zum
ambassador ist also eines themas sie wo
man kann
die letzten zwei jahre und jetzt ist der
influenza und die inflation natürlich
verspricht das erste soziale medizin
community ohne sich selber ruf baut und
kreativität hat dass die marke tätig
repräsentiere das pech an die
werbemacher schluss am end wie die marke
und das ist wie so dass es jetzt so weit
so gehabt
wird heute ein neues kleidergeschäft
eröffnet werden ganz selbstverständlich
influenza aus dem lifestyle bereich
eingeladen
als gegenleistung berichten diese dann
über den anlass auf ihren sozialen
kanälen die schweizer schauspielerin zoe
pastell wird oft eingeladen zu
modeschauen rund um die welt die
18-jährige hat 162 tausend follower mit
denen sie ihre erlebnisse trägt jetzt
sagen ja das so gemacht wurden facebook
und anderen plattformen wie zum beispiel
aus einem wo mich gibt es auch an
trainer fragen ich habe das jetzt
verkaufte york fangen mit dem ganz
witzig und dann ich habe das portal frau
instagram und das profil gemacht aber
natürlich einfach privat vorteile
polster irgendwas einmal und handelt von
emails poster über sache mir einfach
spaß gemacht haben und dann halt immer
noch ihren perfektionismus der hände
dann werden wir das perfekt und ausgesät
und irgendwie will das war einfach spaß
ebenso als kreieren nun ein bild war
super für die leute ich hab kein problem
und das kennt ihr bestimmt alle trockner
und ermöglicht vielleicht für verrückt
erklären denn ich benutze kann praktisch
alles das heißt abschminken kochen
gesicht ein kleiner eincremen und jetzt
ganz vergessen zu erwähnen dass ihr mit
meinem krabat kurz den gleich anwenden
werde 15 prozent auch das ganze
sortiment habt und jahres hat das
auffangen um die frau überhaupt ist das
überhaupt nicht ich habe dann einfach
auch jeden tag alt bist ok das kommt gut
an ich sehe da posten irgendwie bericht
apps und haben das dann irgendwie so in
den alltag integriert und tagesstätte
vor circa einer halbwegs offen
das ist meist der fall so wird wo du mit
dem reinen sauerstoffs und die
organisierte bis wolkig oder das
shooting oder sein
ich wurde einfach verschiedene meister
und ein ich habe mein muss selbst dafür
machen und machen das und und wann bis
wann dann machen das und glauben das es
klappt und nicht ab inspiration und
verschiedenes auch aber nur gibt es
nicht
was ich mir aber im moment an hoffe dass
man vielleicht komplett ich dass ich
heraus schauspielerin fuß gefasst haben
ist mir eigentlich egal wo
und dass ich halt immer noch immer nur
positiv
die virtuelle community ist die
eigentliche währung je mehr follower
desto mehr einfluss die influenza mit
der größten gefolgschaft werden dann
auch von agenten und
vermittlungsagenturen umgarnt
es herrscht goldgräberstimmung um die
lukrativsten geschäftsfelder wird
gekämpft
ich glaube dass die ganze schweiz mit
der einwohnerzahl hat aber zum teil
verflogen sein vertrauen benötige ist
also die lizenz mit sich außerhalb des
social media kanal keiner
lehrernachwuchs zwischen digitaler und
realer heute ein produkt oder eine
dienstleistung kaufen will informiert
sich vorgängig im internet nutzt immer
häufiger das smartphone für die
recherche waren es früher persönliche
empfehlungen sind es heute die post von
influenza die unser kaufverhalten
beeinflussen produkte integriert und
darüber kommuniziert
[Musik]
im endeffekt von moldawien oder eine
spannende content bringt dh man muss das
thema setzte und auch eine figur die
sache über der katalyse spiel und das
tag für tag welche moralischen oder sich
unterhalten
der sprecherrat also dass schon große
druck kommen und das muss eigentlich
aber ein trend werden einige hunde
zahlen 100 musiker aus der antike und
das muss man sich wie groß die und
gerade junge mann so viel verantwortung
getan damit sich daran gewöhnen
von diesem sozialen druck ist war der
kaffee in manuela junge wenig zu spüren
die ehemalige marketing fachfrau genießt
den erfolg
oder wie es so ausdrücken würden sie
reitet die welle und verdient damit
gutes geld
2012 wenn ihr wörter im kitesurfen ist
das mich lustig kp2 und mittlerweile
immer mehr content generieren
ausgerüstet mit professionellem
equipment suchen manuela und ihr partner
james nach einer geeigneten location für
das heutige shooting
wie hätte mir fotografieren
wenn ich aufhöre zu windig mit location
gefunden
leider ist doch eh windig wo ist mir
bewölkt dabei mich auf höchstem niveau
dass unsere station frauen und natürlich
ist wirklich vorbereiten hohes gut
vor wenigen jahren wäre für ein werbe
shooting eine agentur beauftragt worden
dank neuester technologie entstehen die
bilder heute weniger aufwendig im
zweierteam
[Musik]
das neue produkt das bariton fach
platzieren je nach damit aktivitäten
also ist doch nicht dass sie immer im
weg sie also oftmals ist es nur minimal
von politik und schule zusammen
eva brand geldzusagen tour seit wir das
produkt das ich verbrachte und hatte ich
sehe verschiedene influenza zwischen
flügel stelle also zu uns vorstellen
einmal das sagte manuela das tun was sie
macht sich aktiv fitness live sein
und dann gab es mir das produkt ist er
wolle heißt es dass sie muss profis auch
leer
beim englisch ab und zu machen ihrer
vorschlag sei klug das möchte ich gern
machen sieht der vorstand bei stars
bevor die sich posten manuela und james
ein gutes bild inszeniert wird es auf
ihren instagram account geladen und mit
den entsprechenden hashtags versehen
diese wiederum sind mit den sponsoren
verlinkt klicken die follower auf den
entsprechenden link landen sie
automatisch auf dem kanal des sponsors
der werbekreis ist geschlossen
das erfolgsgeheimnis ist simpel zeigt
manuela ihren rund 27.000 fans ein
produkt in einem instagram bild macht
sie damit eine unterschwellige
empfehlung die von ihren verloren als
tipp einer freundin empfunden wird und
nicht als plumpe werbung doch nicht klar
deklarierte empfehlungen gelten als
schleichwerbung
als ich natürlich interessant daran der
kollegs das produkt für die lässig dann
hat das regel in andere qualität für die
empfänger vor der botschaft wieder einen
seite bezahlt wurde und ich empfehle dir
das angebot von dem herzen ich flog ich
versuche so empfehlungen als mit
kommerzieller schien es mir als content
creators oder in trance und wie man uns
nicht wir machen hat das ganze ein
bisschen menschlicher weil wir sind ganz
normale menschen wie halt jeder antrag
das ist genau das was menschen wollen
yvonne reale gesichter hinter den
kulissen also haben wir ja wie ein
kontakt zu mir sie können sich mit mir
austauschen können mir auf twitter
schreiben oder so oder mir auf instagram
folgen und gucken was ich sonst noch so
machen ich glaube das macht einfach wenn
man dann so etwas wie eine empfehlung
bekommt das ist wie als würde man von
einer freundin oder so eine empfehlung
einen tipp bekommen also ich glaube dass
das ist wirklich wieso dieses phänomen
in friseur einfach immer mehr auch
wächst und die soll so erfolgreich ist
wie der schweizerische
lauterkeitskommission gibt's bereits im
grundsatz hat ja so ihre praxis ihres
legic vom luther greift die sogenannte
grundsatz verfasst und im rahmen vor dem
bürgerlichen grundsatz zur tragik und
clown erkennbarkeit von kommerzieller
kommunikation und das ist medienneutral
formuliert gilt als eine social media
kann was ich angefangen habe es vor
einigen jahren habe ich einfach von
transparenz war mir sehr wichtig das hat
meine zuschauerinnen wissen ob sie jetzt
ein gekauftes produktes oder nicht ob es
etwas ist was mir zugeschickt wurde oder
nicht
und das war mir einfach sehr wichtig das
mitzuteilen und deshalb habe ich
angefangen so diese unboxing videos zu
machen wo ich quasi vor der kamera
einfach zeige so was mir alles
zugeschickt wird
the amazing
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt um mich in
migros rauszustellen und war ich bin so
kugel gucken was ich alles bekomme
sondern eher dass eben diese transparenz
da ist interessant gruppe perlendes
influence marketing wo gerade legal
oberflächlich oder künstlich depots zu
werden und gehweg gestellt wird was ich
jetzt da wirklich der wert für der wehr
betrieben die für das unternehmen
woher das immerhin doch zahlt hat
beschwerden ihrer jedermann luther
kommission prüft nötig man das interesse
hat oder nicht mal aus direkt betroffen
sich notwendig es braucht einfach
beschwerte damit luther kings
kommissionen fall beurteilt und die
themen sind kann jedermann beschwerden
ihren mann muss aber persönlich nervt
sie verpasst
man muss einfach mehr beschwerden
vollständig ausfüllen und dann ist
verfahren in gang gebracht
mein name ist tasci marko ich bin freier
journalist in hamburg
und ich habe für die zeit in einem
artikel versucht influenza zu werden
vier wochen lang habe ich für mich
sozusagen fotografiert oder
fotografieren lassen habe meine freundin
instrumentalisiert um fotos von mir zu
machen habe mir den hund meiner
schwester ausgeliehen um sozusagen
beliebtheit hinterher zu erlangen und
habe versucht influenza zu werden
richtig gut hat das ganze nicht geklappt
nicht ganz ernst gemeint war der
selbstversuch des 32 jährigen
journalisten das ziel seines experiments
talentfrei schnell berühmt und reich
werden
[Musik]
er hat gesagt ich hätte gerne eine
frisur wie ein influenza weit vorher
waren jahre ungefähr so also nicht nicht
sehr tauglich hat hat die hat die arme
frisur noch überhaupt nicht verstanden
und hat gesagt ja was das risiko den
franzosen ich wusste es auch nicht genau
dann hat sie mir dazu die frisur gemacht
die die so jeder darf jedes mitglied der
deutschen nationalmannschaft er hat also
im oben bist du mehr oder seite weg
dieses system des folgendes und befolgt
werden es folgt zu seinen eigenen regeln
dann gibt es zum beispiel den hashtag
follow für follow ja das heißt wenn man
seine inhalte mit diesem hashtag für
seht versieht dann kommuniziert man wenn
ihr mir folgt folge ich euch zurück und
da sozusagen die anzahl der follower
zumindest in der theorie die währung ist
tauscht man sozusagen denn die währung
gegeneinander aus dann habe ich einfach
mehr und du hast du verloren mehr
das system funktioniert aber natürlich
dann nur für die für den bodensatz von
instagram nun aber dann war ich
mindestens im boden satz drin also
vorher war ich gar nicht in der
nahrungskette und dann war ich ganz
unten
als ich da tausend kontakte mehr erkauft
hatte konnte ich mich auf dieser
plattform anmelden und konnte mich für
verschiedene produkte bewerben hat aber
nicht funktionieren also ich habe ein
angebot ein einen unternehmen hat
positiv auf meine bewerbung des
instruments an geantwortet sie haben sex
spielzeuge hergestellt die wollten
vibratoren vermarkten aber als sie dann
die haben dann erst ja gesagt aber ich
glaube dann haben sie meine nein mein
profil analysiert und haben gesehen dass
sich sozusagen sieht man ja dann
deutlich an dem verlauf der follower
zahlen dass dir jemand offensichtlich
gekauft gekaufte follower hat und dann
haben sich zurückgezogen
wahrscheinlich wollten sie eben ihr
qualitativ hochwertiges produkt was ist
glaube ich war nicht beschmutzen indem
sie irgendwie ein fake influenza
benutzen für ihren ferien wie beratung
kann ja verstehen
dies weil du sie sich an eine vierte
britische die jene was mehrere machen
könnt ihr nun verkaufte was der markt
ist positiv profit zu machen oder und
repression und dass die ehemals größte
sich regel wurden die produkte die das
heißt wie viele hätten in vielen
falschen kanal zusammen das heißt noch
ein homogenes der polster hat wenn
längere zeit auf einem niedrigen puls
auf dem infos über das engagement was
höchst natürlich für die schweiz werden
ein follower der posten frei sie schert
das heißt noch eine heike der kanal
wieder da ich habe irgendwie das gefühl
dass das ganze in florenz dass also das
thema ist
fünf jahre war der künstler gar nicht so
richtig wagen auf facebook und und
instagram klinik promised city radio
fernseh warwick und ansporn zu indischer
zum ersten mal sitzen medien hätten
private paradies für freiheit und hat
einen eigenen kanal und das gibt es bei
allen anderen medien zu den
herkömmlichen medien ist das nicht mehr
gefordert
social media ist es gar nicht möglich
sie also wahrscheinlich eine ganz
spannende frage entweder diskutieren als
stets das 954 weitere länder wo ich
wirklich glück seid und social media
facebook ist ein hype das verstehen
weder leiden das ist jetzt schon videos
geht so langsam geht was interessiert
mich nicht was die anderen menschen
darstelle oder viel hunters das heißt
die plattform ist nicht einfach die
plattformen sind kriegen also irgendwann
zugleich wir uns ja schon so viel für
die energie jobs oder es ist noch viel
größerer projekte jetzt einmal machen
mit europa park mit schafen
das heißt mit denen die bürger und sie
dürfte kostet auch mit der trainer
das finde ich spannend sind also offline
computer internet wie sender die
interaktion ein wettervorschau schlagen
sie eine leistung
ja jetzt eine steuer das video mit der
europa park vorsitz video da bringt so
sehr am 12 über den mittagstisch und
integratives strand oder schaut jetzt
habe man erwartet hatte
da am laptop sondern wirklich so dass
sie mobil unterwegs und ich habe vor das
stimmt am sonntag haben wir haben zwölf
uhr mittags und geschichte wach was
mache ich als handwerker und dann ja gut
los mit like und punkte marke und
kommentieren da jetzt eine steile
nach 30 sekunden an jetzt ein nicht
wunder gleichkommen sagen ja jetzt läuft
jetzt eine minute schon 180 kommentar
nach drei minuten ein schnelles tor
idrissou vor die aufgenommen
das heißt nicht dass es zwischen ihm
wohl nicht erhalten haben bin ich dass
auch diese und die damen gewinnspiel
geht aber darum dass man sie kolleg
markiert wo man gern gegeben erlebnis
ganz wie hat jetzt nicht erforscht
musik kommentar ist überwältigend
wirklich class nach jetzt nach sieben
minuten zu sie kommen da schnell dass
ich heute so kleine kinder irgendwie
sachen zahllose wie ihre hautcreme oder
sogar mit ihnen leben in europa partner
wirklich alle jetzt
designer david merkle tasche kann mit
einem vorsteuer kann sich jetzt zum
beispiel animierte zahlen
das leichte kleider kaufen aber trotzdem
hat immer im hinterkopf dass ich glaube
immer nur in der schweiz geschaffen und
das hobby blieben dort hat eine
altersgrenze luftballon
und das machte das hobby machte spaß
und sobald spaß und trug dann stimmt
irgendwie habe ich jetzt mache nach
eineinhalb stunden 24 tour sieger führt
und schon fast 5000 kommentar es ist
krass das ist mega also das ist in der
schweiz steht man das so gut wie gar
nicht dass das eine der schweizer so
schafft mit schweizer verloren
mein feind sehr froh kann
privat bin ich schon meistens trug
schwere probiert aber so kommentar
reagiert das kruzifix zu bauen die nur
froh kann oder
antworten antworten
ja und das ist die beziehung von einem
follower zu seinem social media oder
influenza nennen wir in der wissenschaft
paar asozial
das bedeutet dass die beziehung
einseitig ist also informationen werden
nur in eine richtung verteilt denn
natürlich sind instruments hat zwar
halbwegs erreichbar für ihre follower
und kriegen manchmal manchmal bekommen
wolle auch einen kommentar zurück aber
in der regel produziert der influenza
die inhalte und der follower verfolgt
sie ja und dieses phänomen nennt man
para soziale beziehungen auf soziale
medien und der konsum von idealen
darstellungen das leben anderer
glücklich macht das ein heißes thema in
der forschung die studien deuten eher
darauf hin dass das durchaus unglücklich
machen kann gerade wenn man ohnehin
nicht einen guten psychischen
konstitution ist ja wir sehen nämlich
nur idealisierte ausschnitte aus dem
leben anderer und deren deren straucheln
sehen wenn ich ja
[Musik]
viele ideale haben mit den echten leben
nichts zu tun man ja vor zwei jahren die
kampagne gestartet
echtes leben da diese sowieso eigentlich
um das thema gang aber meine profi wie
sie das glauben ich bin ich ausgestiegen
die kristallklare meer mit dem jetskis
und geprüft und unter palmen liege
sondern das lahme vielmehr bedeutet und
für die meisten jugendlichen oder für
die erwachsenen heißt minto geschaffene
alltag erledigt wie sache klappt und wie
sie misserfolg aller art zu der einfluss
von social media auf unser leben
beschäftigt forschung und wirtschaft
gleichermaßen eltern und lehrerschaft
wiederum fragen sich ob soziale medien
ob zu viel internetkonsum die heutige
jugend gefährdet lohrs jeder nur von der
pro juventute kennt das medienverhalten
von jugendlichen das sind die die da
sind wir dann die person ist eben nur
probiert haben sich die jugendlichen
jetzt künstlich in die situation
hineinversetzen also wie das ist wenn
man so offensichtlichen erfolg hat und
bei mir zu dir oder danke finster gramm
ist ja da auf andere soziale netzwerk
welches mmo was die andere für erfolg an
und deshalb ist verglichen und das kann
je nach dem radar gehabt dass man sich
weniger wert fühlt dass man es auch nie
in einer depression und zärtliche sachen
der druck sich immer von der besten
seite zu zeigen ist auch für influenza
dem australischen model s serono wurde
alles zu viel
sie machte ihren zusammenbruch
öffentlich und zog sich aus den sozialen
medien zurück
also die alten ganz medial sehr
aufwändig so iris profil gründet also
und stellung bezogen hat so gysi vettel
zeigt was ich mache hat als strand
verteilt peak sie was sie findet dass
vettel ich mir drei tage schnitt gab es
seitdem mit dem buch möglichst flache
skater und ihre schwester hätte ich mal
60 seitige 330 fertig macht wie sie das
vierte liga-sieg folge haben dass das
komposter also die ganze arbeit die
hinter die wirtin durchschnitt sichtbar
gemacht
[Musik]
der intensive konsum von sozialen medien
hat hat vielerlei einfluss auf die
psyche von dem jungen menschen
es gibt neue studien die zeigen dass
dadurch ein bisschen oberflächliches
denken oder oberflächliche das
sozialverhalten entsteht andererseits
denke ich kann das sehr inspirierend
sein man kann auf social media gute
vorbilder finden man kann jede menge
wissen zu bestimmten themen finden und
dadurch auch in einer ganz anderen
geschwindigkeit lernen als das früher
möglich war
der boxer in den wald wo sie auch
wachsen sie klären oder scanner und
entwickler dementsprechend entwickelt am
entsprechenden strategie wir sind mit
einer situation umgehen und für uns
erwachsene ist ein pflichttermin der
okay mir haben
das wird uns stress sie haben aber für
nicht so ganz natürlich gehört damit
umgehen könne sich sogar positiv nutzen
glaubt christian sichert ein problem
dann ist aber bei uns aber sexy aus dem
mittel situation wohl mehr jugendliche
sind in diesen besserung
unter anderem welt
audios zwei schirme okay das wäre für
euch haben erklären was das ist und dies
auch jugend und die krones-aktie das ist
also mit dem zweiten mal das ist cool
das wird der rest sei doris entlockt
gesteigert das duo piskol fink bitteres
bildschirm und kommentieren und wir sind
gerade am media workshops medienprofis
wofür der pro juventute art motiviert
im rahmen von einem workshop die mir
eigentlich verschiedene themen
thematisiere kind gelange wo sie
beschäftigt das thema internet social
media youtube eigner versteht nichts von
mir abholen und damit dem kind
besprechen
zeit für ein wunder konnte palestine
groß - wurde
[Musik]
kleine und große kinder so hat die
flüsse also in pflanzen zum beispiel
lisa und lena wodurch musik liberia sind
und über kfz werden meistens wird
zum beispiel die dass die präsentierte
an das leiden und wenn das bild feel
like seit dem 5 wir werden sie glaubt
kennzeichnung hashtag weg und dann ist
eigentlich los ist epic ist transparenz
ist ein großes thema im influenza
marketing ich denke zum einen dass wir
manchmal jugendliche unterschätzen was
ihre sensibilität für werbemaßnahmen
angeht zahlreiche studien zeigen nämlich
dass auch schon kinder im
grundschulalter sehr wohl in der lage
sind überzeugungs versuche zu erkennen
zum anderen denke ich dass die
regulierung von staatlicher seite hier
natürlich ein bisschen hinterher ist
hinter der praxis aber nach und nach
mehr aufholt das zeigt sich daran dass
inzwischen die kennzeichnungspflichten
deutlich strenger sind als das noch am
anfang der fall war
thoma irgendwas natürlich ist gerade
jetzt haben wir die auch mal die gestapo
stadt und sagt du siehst wie vielleicht
eine 20.000 ja ja das war aber so
bearbeitet es wirklich geht noch 20
minuten nur 20 minuten reist ich
verdränge ich wahrscheinlich noch mehr
spaß macht uns selbst überrascht mich ja
nicht mit deinen dienst mit mir damit
mein leibnitz
du kommst mir jetzt nicht helfen
okay was brauchst kannst schauen was als
nächstes kommt ich habe das lustiger das
heißt immer innerhalb jeder koch werde
so aber sie läuft sich mit half das ist
wie dies das artet nach alles wenn nicht
hilft
das war dort zu einer katastrophe führen
er hat mir meinen kaffee machen wollen
und die kaffeemaschine ist danach kaputt
gewesen nun kaffee
das ist echt gern eins kein rezept von
zwei minuten hatte das hinbekommt und
auf diese kaffeemaschine ist nur eines
sondern es waren zwei knöpfe traut dass
wir großen und kleinen café also hat der
mitteilung
doch du kannst die anleitung lesen jetzt
an was als nächstes kommt wo ist mein
handy
sie haben die stadt geht an anderen lese
ich die arbeit und selben und schaue was
als nächstes kommt cello mafia boss
sie steht auch kurz und bei dir hast du
mich nicht mehr los gewesen
ich denke es ist also es kann gut oder
schlecht sein das kommt drauf an wie man
es macht ich hab selber ein acker und
versuche
auch ein bisschen was zu posten aber ja
mir ist jetzt so wichtig es ist mit
meinem beruf oder sogar ganz ehrlich hat
die reden wir das können sie nicht
gestartet werde meine themen
internetdienst aber mich interessiert ob
er operiert jessica sarah mit reese ist
oder gar nicht fassen dass der vorstand
das ist nicht interessiert oder ob er
thomas das jetzt zwei birken wachsen
also ich wirklich individuell aber dass
das überhaupt aber passiert das ist
schon krass
oder dass das seehäuser so zeige klar
und dann mehr informationen
entsprechenden botschaften navas selber
dazu sagen
scary das sind natürlich genau weiß was
man gerne mache was man gerne auch mal
gern trinken was man gerne haben möchte
das ist schon unglaublich omega sophie
brief glaube jeder muss selber so
entscheiden wie viele online sein will
oder nicht für mich ich habe mir einfach
hat grenzen gesetzt wo ich sagte okay
das ist wirklich privat das muss ich
nicht unbedingt mit der großen welt
teilen
aber für andere leute die denken hat je
mehr ich poste desto mehr erfolgreicher
werde ich und vielleicht können sie
deshalb nicht abschalten
[Musik]
ein neuer wald gegangen
es ist auch nicht so ist wahrscheinlich
immer gewisse sachen sind dazu auch hier
dass man auch das bild ja es gibt
positive und negative aspekte der ganze
motor wirklich so hässlich wie sie aus
sechs metern euro
das gleiche gilt fürs marketing das
marketing ist eine so langwierigen uns
ausreichend sichert bis neues ausdenken
so bietet er doch unter einem gletscher
begeistert und ausmachen also zunächst
die haie zufolge türen
die produktplatzierung oder
werbemaßnahmen die häuser dem begriff
influenza marketing fast schon eine
negative konnotation verleihen dass die
sich deutlich verändern werden
dahingehend dass souveräner inhalte
eingebettet werden dass sie überzeugungs
versuchen nicht mehr so plump gestaltet
werden als gedacht mit jedem wurf kurz
und schlagt entfernte klar doch jetzt
mal das große geld machen
aber nachher zuweilen vlies oder die
jugend geht's nicht was es aber gibt ich
hab's nie vergessen wie es ist jung zu
[Musik]
lustig ist das hübsche 18-jährige
sichere die heutige jugend muss also
abstand werden
also man hört immer zeit für mich ganz
oft einfach mitnimmt verstanden
und für erwachsene ist eigentlich
problem dass sich keiner vorstellen aber
aus der jugend gemacht
und wenn man sieht dass es heikel der
finanzkrise mit und dass das die jugend
ganz okay zum 1
[Musik]